e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
jacobo su propuesta de tesis es
imposible
ese fue el primer comentario que recibí
cuando estaba iniciando mi tesis de
grado allá en septiembre del 2012 y
claro en la posición de estudiante no
quedaba más que acatar la instrucción y
trabajar en otro proyecto impuesto y una
vez más se repite la historia
un proyecto con el alcance de mejorar la
calidad de vida de una comunidad un
proyecto con el potencial de poder
resolver una problemática social latente
ha sido rechazado y guardaba en el baúl
de los recuerdos
les suena familiar esta historia
es decir de grado es el proyecto de
graduación es algo que por siglos se ha
practicado y aunque han habido mejoras
en las técnicas y metodologías de
investigación aún hay mucho camino por
recorrer
qué está pasando con las investigaciones
de tesis de grado en nuestro centro de
educación superior
ese ha sido mi tema de investigación
como doctor ante en ciencias de la
educación
y uno de mis hallazgos ha sido que el
estudiante al decidir
especializarse hasta en marketing
recursos humanos o finanzas
automáticamente se colocan antiojeras y
limitan el alcance de sus proyectos
especulando que éstos sólo pueden ser
realizados en sus orillas ramas de una
determinada empresa y esto no puede ser
más diametralmente opuesto a lo que
necesita nuestra sociedad esto requiere
un cambio de raíz de pensamiento
no podemos excluir al estudiante del
proceso de entendimiento de la realidad
social es como pretender quitar al
objeto de estudio del contexto que lo
percibe y lo concibe
es por eso que brindado la respuesta a
esto una de las principales actividades
que hemos estado realizando con mis
estudiantes es el denominado tanque de
tiburones
partiendo de la aclamada serie
estadounidense star tank donde invitó a
dos o tres personas expertos en su área
de conocimiento y ellos enriquecen
constructivamente los proyectos al final
de la clase claro algunos terminan
masacrados pero esa retroalimentación ha
sido doble guía y a eso yo lo he
denominado inteligencia colectiva
y otra de las actividades de aprendizaje
y enseñanza que hemos desarrollado en
clase es el simposio de expertos donde
invitó a otras 23 personas diferentes al
primer grupo y ellos tienen un espacio
de 40 minutos una hora donde comparten
experiencias vivenciales y sus proyectos
de alcance social esto ha permitido
crear un puente de las necesidades
sociales hacia el aula de la clase y
también hacer ese puente de los libros
de texto en acción a esto lo he
denominado cultura colaborativa
mi motivación para todo esto se remonta
hace muchos años en el 2002
cuando están en secundaria una de mi
clase favorita siempre fue física
elemental eran los lunes parece entonces
la catedrática estaba fuera del aula y
nosotros estábamos trabajando y los
ejercicios de clase
llegamos a un tema que todavía no había
sido explorado en clase entonces empecé
a unir fórmulas unas con otras y de
repente creé una ecuación que resumía
como tres fórmulas en 1
me sentí orgulloso de mi colaboración a
la clase fui corriendo de la profe y le
dije profe he creado una ecuación a la
cual ella dio mi cuaderno no se tomó ni
dos segundos y me dijo hijo esa ecuación
hasta el final del libro
ya se imaginarán la expresión entonces
al ver mi cara de tristeza ella puso su
mano sobre mi cabeza siempre fui marcha
parte de la clase y me dijo pero no dudo
que descubras algo más adelante
y eso ha hecho eco en mi vida hasta el
día de hoy no puedo estar pasivo sin
poder aportar contribuir en algo que
mejor es lo que es mi círculo de
influencia y así como quiero compartir
con ustedes parte de los proyectos con
los que hemos estado trabajando con mis
estudiantes uno de ellos ampliación de
la cobertura de clases extracurriculares
para niños el riesgo social en san pedro
sula
diseñar plan de manejo ambiental para la
microcuenca laguna verde en santa
barbara déficit de vivienda social en
san pedro sula buenas prácticas
derivados e impacto ecológico el
procesamiento de café de alta calidad en
santa barbara honduras
todos estos proyectos tienen un
denominador en común
el alcance de estos proyectos es el
contexto social de donde se desenvuelve
el estudiante a esto lo he denominado
investigación social significativa
partiendo de tres pilares
interdependientes donde el primero
consiste en la gestión de los sistemas
de investigación en nuestros centros de
educación superior
el enfoque de las universidades se ha
distorsionado y desplazado de en lugar
de brindar soluciones a problemas
latentes en nuestra sociedad hacia
beneficios personales particulares
y es por eso que todos hemos pasado por
esto no existe esa retroalimentación de
necesidades que hay en la sociedad hacia
los currículums de nuestros centros de
educación superior
el segundo pilar consiste en la creación
de esos un gremio de investigadores
docentes representantes de cada una de
las universidades de nuestra ciudad al
igual que en cualquier empresa donde
existe el benchmarking entre plantas
germanas estos docentes investigadores
tendrán la facultad de poder interactuar
entre sí a través de la cultura
colaborativa e inteligencia colectiva
para implementar las mejores prácticas
de enseñanza y aprendizaje en nuestras
aulas y emigrar de esfuerzos
centralizados individuales a un sistema
de distribución colaborativo y el tercer
pilar no por eso menos importante
consiste en que el requisito de
graduación en las tesis de grado de
nuestro centro de educación superior ya
no será un libro empolvándose en la
biblioteca no será una investigación
social significativa donde el expediente
resolverá una problemática social
latente en su contexto donde se
desenvuelven
y quiero enfatizar
toda esta sinergia toda esta energía en
la jaula de clases gracias a mi equipo
mis estudiantes los aportes de ellos las
contribuciones de ellos los sentimientos
y emociones de ellos qué aportan en la
clase son diferentes áreas de
conocimiento y todos al unísono
alrededor de una sola idea enriqueciendo
la a través de la cultura colaborativa y
la inteligencia colectiva ha hecho que
las clases sean extraordinarias y es así
como nosotros rompemos esa barrera esa
premisa de proyectos imposibles muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]